in this lesson we're going to talk about
translating sentences into equations so
some key words that you want to be
familiar with and understand are these
ones here so let's start off at the top
so when you see more than
that means add
when you see less than that means
subtract but what sometimes students get
a little confused by is when you say you
know
the number is
2 less than x what students will do is
they'll say 2 minus x because they're
trying to translate like in a direct way
they're saying 2 less than
x but that's actually not correct what
you want is you want x and 2 less than
that means you're taking 2 away from x
okay so don't do a direct translation
when you're
using the phrase you're less than
okay and then product means multiplier
times quotient means divide and another
thing that students and i wonder about
when you're doing the quotient is you
know which one is divided by which one
well if they say the quotient of uh
five quotient of 5 and 10
you take the first number that goes in
the numerator and the second number that
goes in the denominator
okay and then sum means add difference
means subtract and then if you see the
word is that means equals and of
means times so review these and memorize
those that will help you let's go into a
couple examples go ahead and pause the
video
see if you can do these on your own and
we'll go through them together so the
first one says
the product of a number and 6
is 2 less than the quotient of 105.
what is the number
okay so let's translate this into an
equation and we'll solve it so the
product of a number in 6. we don't know
what the number is so let's just call
that n for number okay the product means
we're multiplying so product of n and 6
is means equals
2 less than the quotient of 105. so the
quotient of 105 means 100 divided by 5
2 less than that means we're subtracting
2. okay so we've set up our equation now
let's just solve it so 100 divided by 5
is 20.
okay
n times 6 is just 6 times n or 6n
20 minus 2 is 18.
divide both sides by 6 and you can see
that n equals 3
and you got it
okay let's go to number 2 here jane is 2
more than 3 times her daughter's age if
her daughter is 12 how old is jane
okay so let's see if we can write this
equation here so jane we'll just say j
for jane
is okay equals
two more than so two plus
three times her daughter's age so let's
just say her daughter's age in this case
they say it's 12 so we'll put 12 in for
her daughter's age right
okay so all we have to do is simplify
this one pretty easy we've got 2 plus 3
times 12 is 36
so j equals 2 plus 36 which is 38 and
you got it so again knowing how to
translate sentences into equations using
these terms and phrases will make it a
lot easier when you see these problems
on the act